[Music]
good to be alive and good to be beyonce
queen bee gave life as she belted out
her oscar-nominated song be alive at the
academy awards on sunday
[Music]
the singer opened the show with the
performance of the empowering anthem
which is featured on the king richards
soundtrack
be who wore a custom neon green david
coma dress with a high split and diamond
jewelry performed from a compton tennis
court where the williams family once
practiced
oscars
i want you to tell these people where we
are
[Music]
yeah i think you can sing it like you
mean it tell them where we are
[Music]
the performance in which everyone wore
neon green included members of the
compton community and an appearance from
one extra special guest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yep right there in front of beyonce is
her ten-year-old daughter blue ivy
rocking shades as she performs the
choreography with skill and passion
there was even this moment where you can
see blue sitting in front of her mama
singing along to the lyrics
[Music]
beyonce's performance also included a
cameo from the stars of king richard
sanaya sydney who played venus and demi
singleton who played serena
i'm a huge beyonce fan so i'm so excited
and speaking of the real venus in serena
before beyonce wowed everyone the two
tennis stars were tasked with
introducing her
ladies and gentlemen beyonce
[Music]
which was very fitting considering king
richard is about their rise to fame
alongside their father and coach richard
we're proud of this
thank you so much
the song be alive which beyonce co-wrote
alongside artist dixon is nominated for
best original song it's surreal honestly
i've been producing music for quite a
while submitting songs to our team i
never expected that all this would
happen off a song that i submitted so in
days before her highly anticipated
performance et got a look at the tennis
court that served as beyonce stage
as you can see the neon green surfaces
were freshly painted
and at the time an eyewitness told e.t
beyonce filmed a week before the actual
show
beyonce going beyonce
ahead of the big night oscar's producer
will packard tease the fire beyonce was
going to bring and on the red carpet
celebs like chloe and halle and diddy
couldn't help but gush in excitement
over queen bee's oscar performance and
nomination
how excited are you for the beyonce
performance tonight
we're so excited we are very excited
you have a little extra insight
we're gonna be just a surprise we know
she's gonna kill him yeah what are you
looking forward to tonight i want the
beyonce to win
yeah i want beyonce to win well too yeah
yeah
thank you for the save yeah will and
beyonce i'm root for everybody though
really you know what i'm saying but i
would love to see my friends win
[Music]